[Music]
so this is a story that's currently
under investigation but these are the
facts so far and they already sound
[ __ ] insane so you know the country
guitar yeah yes in qatar these four guys
approached this factory guitar i would
say country guitar my bad i did too but
i'm not stupid so i just figured
no you didn't even know anything idiot
so there's these four guys they demand
entry to this factory they come up to
the factory armed with guns they go let
us in so they let these guys in the
season pass let me in
so they go to this factory and then
i guess for some weird reason there's a
bunch of dogs in this factory and the
men are like oh come here come here so
the dogs come running up like they're
you know they think they're getting at
food
these guys start opening fire and they
killed 29 dogs and puppies oh my god
and that's all they did and left what
kind of factory was this that had 30
dogs
they probably have a house next to the
factory and they keep barking in the
morning i think it's not that the
factory is in the business of having
dogs there's happen to be dogs in this
like factory why do they got 29 one of
the guys in that like one of the shooter
guys like said that it's because one of
those dogs bit his son or some [ __ ]
so i will kill him all yeah so they
don't know like what if that's true or
that's under investigation but that's
the facts that happened is they killed
executed 29 dogs and puppies
yeah i want to know what kind of dogs
some of these drugs were pregnant too
because some of them it's okay look
because i'm all like if it's 29
pomeranians maybe it's okay because they
they're [ __ ] so yapping pretty
annoying yeah i mean they're cute but
damn they're so loud it tells me they're
not wild i'm raising guitars is katara
is qatar like villa village like middle
east uh no it's it's very it's actually
kind of
nice i thought it's next to uh dubai do
they have just they probably have a
bunch of like random straight by the
emirates because um don was telling me a
story so don is our uh our buddy that's
like in special operations the dreamboat
the dream boat in the marine corps yeah
and so he was saying when he was over in
afghanistan and their job was to train
up the afghan troops to fight their own
war
they found out one of the other dudes
was um like molesting kids or something
like that
so they beat the living [ __ ] out of them
like you can't be [ __ ] doing this on
our watch
either that we're gonna have to kick you
out or report you
and uh
after that happened
they had a stray dog that they took in
as their own oh no
and then that dude came
back and killed their like unit dog
because he was like man he couldn't [ __ ]
kids no more yeah yeah yeah so [ __ ]
nuts dude places like this where it's
like it's it's hard because everyone
starting common sense and how you
interact is from a different page
sometimes you know here's a picture of
guitar for just a visual for dope that's
not villagery nah it's not that looks
very modern but that looks better than
that that looks like a [ __ ] rpg video
game is that final fantasy
that's guitar that doesn't look like a
place that has like back backwards
thinking oh sorry i typed midgar
sorry this is asgard
oh that's not guitar no it is guitar oh
actually it looks crazy her guitar
airways is [ __ ] nice though yeah that
[ __ ] is nice it is very nice i've never
been on it have you i have what is it
like very nice
explain it thoroughly
like singapore nice like that or even
better uh different singapore i feel
like is really cool when you're like in
like business class and stuff they have
like the beds and stuff and obviously
you're a fan of asian food and then also
asian airlines usually still are down
for like attractive stewardesses and
stuff yeah they get on they get on their
knees to [ __ ] put a blanket on you
and [ __ ] yeah yeah so i think that's
different i think qatar airways one food
was really good did they get on their
knees though
no no it's not good people get on their
knees in general
yeah uh and then they're [ __ ]
their seats are really really nice their
[ __ ] screens are really really big on
the airplanes and stuff like that will
you find business class no not a guitar
i didn't fly business class guitar but
what the is the food like shawarma
what's the food like i don't [ __ ]
remember what i ate like three years ago
the [ __ ] get back together
i i i remember all i remember my
singapore heirloom i had saute
curry chicken
no i do business class all the time i
remember all my meals
every single one
that's a final fantasy 8.
uh yeah so in qatar i guess i mean they
said they do have a really big problem
not with having too many strays but with
animal abuse in general
they said there's no enforcement of like
if you did something to dogs you're
probably not going to get punished for
it so that's
yeah that's kind of why [ __ ] reach this
level of like you know if if four people
are that audacious that they'll [ __ ]
shoot 29 [ __ ] mold down 29 dogs it's
so hard to say from like these small
articles because i know nobody from that
area so we don't know if it's like a
small incident if it's a representation
of the culture it's just such a small
snippet but it's so sad yeah well in
qatar qatar itself is like actual qatar
uh citizens are outraged about this how
can hell yeah so it's not like we're
looking in going oh that's [ __ ] up and
they're like what yeah
that's the problem they're just as like
they're trying to figure out like how
they can you know improve that problem
of like oh it's inconsequential what you
do to like a dog you know this could be
a dumb question but like do you think
there's more countries in the world that
like domesticate dogs as pets
see them as just animals you know what i
mean that like are synonymous to
raccoons or there's a high level of
domestication of animals in general
right i think that was like we cracked
the code years ago because there was
like this this uh mutual bond that
humans had with animals we evolved we've
had it for a very very very long time
dogs have been longer uh with human like
i guess like like what's the word like
um domestication and and in proximity
than cats or any other animal i'm well
cat's ancient so even before cows no no
seriously no dogs came first i'm just
saying like culturally the way that
people see like that level common sense
the way people see dogs i know that
they're not like white people who's like
like the one of the family members but
that's different like but like having
them around the house
yeah they are fine they're [ __ ]
making not with them because even in
china like when they had the yulin dog
festival it's chinese activist groups
that are against it yeah like they're
they're they don't want [ __ ] dog
eating happening you know instead of
like all of china being like ooh it's a
dog tonight
but that's all i'm saying though you
know what i mean we look at we look like
a qatar uh news article like this and
we're like everybody's on the same page
very equally like this is ridiculous
yeah but i also wonder if the same type
of news went to a majority of the rest
of the world and they didn't necessarily
see it in the same sentimental way that
we have released people would say like
oh dog 29 dogs killed and they spent
high fives all around
29 high fives no any country that's
i think everyone is good
[Laughter]
that's the there's a little caveat
though is that uh
it doesn't really get talked about a lot
because it creates a total different
controversy but the thing that does
differentiate how people see dogs a lot
of times religion
really
because some religions do not see dogs
as
like oh that's not a human that's not
it's unclean or it's this it's that like
they don't value it the same way we're
talking about sda yes we [ __ ] hate
those things you know what my mom tries
to try to make my dog vegetarian and
[ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] man this [ __ ] dog needs
meat man dude did you see those tick
tocks of those like hardcore like vegan
people making their cats vegan and then
you see the cat like my cat's so healthy
and this cat's over here just pranking
yeah
turn the cat the cat
in a patch of furniture
but you literally
there was a video where somebody who was
like a vet was looking at their cat
they're like your cat's going blind like
you need to [ __ ] and they're like my cat
lunch test him
and like they're trying to feed this cat
tofu or like a leaf and the cat starts
fighting him yeah
people are [ __ ] crazy dude that's
pretty rough but but that's what i'm
saying i don't think people are
high-fiving at the death but like
religiously for example
yeah right if you're looking at dogs and
you're just kind of like that's not well
all the world over like in all the earth
religion is one of those things that
kind of backtracks what like humans have
kind of evolved to like whether accept
or reject yeah religions will just
keep that strictly this is how we all
feel it doesn't [ __ ] matter how you
really think yeah
this is where we've governed how we feel
about this kind of a thing yeah well how
many christians eat shrimp
yeah let's talk
they're bottom feeders you're not
supposed to eat shrimp no no bottom
feeders and i'd be eating that [ __ ] all
the time baby
you guys made sure
yeah we made shrimp daddy dude i'm the
worst christian on earth do i love pork
dude yeah and pork yeah you're supposed
to stay away from pork
but that's what that's what the the
problem the reason why i'm saying it
creates a different thing is that uh in
different countries where there's
certain crimes that specific religions
or specific cultures are committing more
you can't really uh say
that you have to just go oh and there
was a big problem that was sort of not
really similar to this but like a
similar issue in britain there were like
these uh gangs of like they called them
like grooming gangs rooming games
haircuts there would be these like
stupid there would be these like
so it's it was mainly i'm like you say
because i feel weird there's mainly one
type of culture that was uh not mainly
one but there was a very distinct
culture that had a lot of these grooming
gangs where they would just take like
young uh british like white girls and
then force them into these prostitution
rings
they had that in japan yeah and so they
when the news was reported they didn't
want to single out who was really behind
it and they just said asian grooming
gangs and all the koreans japanese
everybody was like wow they got really
[ __ ] pissed because it wasn't
primarily them it was a different thing
that also well they just kind of bunch
all asian people together exactly but
don't they call like even indians and
southeast asian and everybody but it
wasn't sick people that were doing it it
wasn't like you know like so all these
other asian groups got pissed and they
were like hey
to save your [ __ ] political
correctness don't dump on all of us yeah
yeah just saying he's [ __ ] doing it
yeah it's like russian and it's like
they just [ __ ] try to beat around the
bush and be like oh asia
my whole of asia yeah but then that's
that's the kind of thing that's
happening right now is they're trying to
avoid creating a different backlash yeah
by naming specifics in crime it just
creates more curiosity yeah and that's
another thing that's happening too with
religion as well like they're not gonna
go oh because this religion believes
this it was probably them or it was
probably that reason they're just gonna
leave it alone publication wise and go
ah you guys figure it out wow damn a lot
of that's left for us to infer and
privately
you know at our own discretion and our
own judgment yeah
it's more like hey you be racist by
yourself yeah you figure it out
[Music]
you